well here with me now to discuss the
latest military developments in Ukraine
is the defense Analyst at the Royal
United Services Institute Dr Alexandra
Walmsley
um we're hearing about the Prime
Minister making this address a huge
amount of money he's going to be giving
to Ukraine how far have Ukraine exceeded
the expectations that we perhaps placed
upon them in their success in this
conflict well I think as we're more than
three months now from the start of the
invasion Ukraine has exceeded all
expectations and that's partly because
the forces are motivated and trained and
at the beginning were equipped with
Western Equipment these enlaw anti-tank
missiles for example proved to be really
effective against the Russian armor so
they fought back you can see from this
map here that the Russian Advance is
still very firmly in the East there's
the whole west of the country where
indeed the ukrainians in the yellow have
made some territorial gains back from
the Russians but this is not not what
Putin and his government thought that
Ukraine would look like at this time no
what is it about the the particular
style of fighting that the ukrainians
are doing that is so effective well
partly they are motivated like like no
other I mean this is for them this is an
existential conflict so they are
prepared to fight but what's been really
noticeable is that the Ukrainian forces
are almost partisan in nature they are
flexible they are adaptable if they see
a change in circumstance they make the
most of it whereas the Russians the
rigid and inflexible and their
Communications seem to be far beyond the
or the back of the of the fighting lines
so that that they're very unable to
change tack if something starts to go
badly so it's interesting so it is about
it's about motivation and being about
being kind of nimble really it really is
Nimble and agile is is the key here and
the ukrainians are maximizing that Dr
Alexander Walmsley thanks very much